[Music]
i like gt actually
i prefer the q4
better turning radius
have a nice day sir
i can't do this goodbye vincent
goodbye then
olivia please don't go out brian there's
paparazzi you're being reckless call me
when you're divorced
people are looking i never thought i
would get hit by a podcast
airheart opens in five days i can't help
this getting out there what if we find
the other guy in the photo and he would
pretend to be a couple
i'll do it olivia allen is gonna go out
with me the famous actress yes the
beautiful one yes with me correct
my sister put you up to this you got me
shout out get ready
say something i'm gonna laugh really
hard i don't understand
are you some kind of sex guy antonio i'm
not a sex thought
[Music]
what's happening here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
antonio this is your first premiere
right
what do you see in my brother he's
decent and kind
of i love you i'm famous too which is
surprisingly hard to find
was that your ex i have been trying to
get her back now to the gems you know
we'll look for what we want out of this
insanity
oh my god when he's here
oh god no nothing happened
and i slept in my pants
see
[Applause]
pictures
[Music]